ça une barre la positionne comme un vrai
challenge du président
la france dégringole dans le classement
des puissances un publi par les erreurs
la vanité et le cynisme des manuels
macron emmanuel macron emmanuel macron
qui a bradé nos fleurons le prétendu
mozart de la finance
on nous avait promis un crack mais le
socrate que nous avons vu est financier
la france orange ma chronique une
seconde marine le pen ne peut pas être
considéré comme un détenu en fin d'après
midi samedi
du début février alors que eric zemmour
va l'être par des donc une heure avant à
lille autant eric zemmour cherchait à
conquérir l'électorat de
valérie pécresse autant marine le pen a
essayé de se positionner en voix on a
des
macros dans une logique de deuxième tour
les français ne sont pas condamnés à
l'abandon ensemble nous allons rendre à
nos compatriotes la france qu'ils aiment
je rendrai aux français leur pays
ça vous parle à la positionne la vraie
challengers du président est d'autre
part ça coucou à aux attaques on pouvait
attendre aux eric zemmour suit deux
volets mythes qui ont vu cette semaine
une france attentive aux personnes les
plus vulnérables bienveillante pour ses
enfants tous ses enfants la grandeur de
notre société se mesure à l'attention
que nous portons à l'égard des plus
vulnérables je pense bien évidemment ou
personnes touchées par le handicap et à
leurs familles
la france a su par le passé mettre en
place de grandes politiques afin
d'assurer aux handicapés leur juste
place dans la société là il y avait un
message subliminal
ils ont bu les deux décidé que ce ne
serait pas l'autre serait la subissent
eh bien on voit bien que des deux côtés
on a choisi d'aller vers d'autres
adversaires
ma première mesure sera de décompte
réalisé et d'augmenter l'allocation
adultes handicapés jusqu'à 1000 euros
mesure que j'ai soutenu
sur les bancs de l'assemblée nationale
passe au gouvernement d' emmanuel macron
qui restait sourd à cette exigence
minimale de justice la fin du discours
est tout à fait intéressante elle est
assez original marine le pen les centres
d'estrade abandonne son public pour
croire que c'est terminé elle va
raconter son histoire
maintenant mes amis je vais prendre
quelques minutes pour vous parler de moi
la politique fait partie de mon
existence
j'ai parfois échoué je suis tombé je me
suis toujours relevé donc c'est un
discours donc de l'ethos cette idée
c'est qu'elle va jouer à fond les doses
que la proximité avec les français c'est
à dire je suis recettes comme les a pris
dans le tourbillon des engagements il ya
eu ce divorce parental la vie en fait
est fait de sacrifices de difficultés
des preuves si rien est sacrifiée
cris en est obtenue est là tous les
codes on va dire de la femme ordinaire
française un peu trans place qu'elle
cherche à délivrer comme une pomme
message c'est une force qu'elle a et que
si on réfléchit bien aucun autre
candidat n'a donc elle a vraiment une
proximité une authenticité qui peut lui
faire gagner peuvent la gagner
l'adhésion notamment de l'électorat
populaire par cette fin elle a peu fait
une bonne prestation
vous êtes ma porte je ne crois ni les
prisons et les embuscades niney
manoeuvre tout commence aujourd'hui
et c'est la branche
[Musique]